is on this ballot too and finally i hate
to say it
but our access to the ballot itself our
right to vote in free and fair elections
is on this ballot so if you listen to
sister kamala at the supreme court
hearings this week
you heard him say that north carolina
republicans targeted black voters
with almost surgical precision and
that's why
everyone i mean everyone needs to make a
plan to vote
and after you make a plan vote your plan
and help your friends and your family
members and your colleagues to make a
plan too
in person early voting started today
mecklenburg county has 33 places where
you can vote
in fact if you look around there's
probably an early voting site
less than a 10-minute drive from you and
it's open right now for voters to cast
their ballot so let's take advantage
of the increased flexibility and the
extended times to vote
as early as safely as possible folks we
have the power
to elect joe biden and kamala harris to
re-elect governor cooper and support
democrats
up and down this ballot we're going to
turn north carolina blue
we're going to make donald trump a
one-term president but we can't do it
without every single vote
so join me in voting early join me in
voting for better health care
join me in voting for reproductive
rights join me in voting for our climate
join me in voting for justice join me in
voting for a roof over
every head and a strong and fair economy
and join me in voting so that we never
lose that right
and vote like you've never voted before
and help me
help me turn this mother out for joe
biden
and kamala harris thank you reverend
you know congressman adams i'm gonna
have to have you come preach at my
church uh
because i think that was a sermon right
there so thank you so much uh
for your remarks and for encouraging us
to preserve
and to reclaim those things that are
most
important to us you know i am a
beneficiary of the affordable care act
i am on the insurance plan through the
affordable care act
and i was gravely concerned um by the
hearings this week with the supreme
court
nominee along with all the other things
that are going on to try and
dismantle a health care system if that
is something that is concerning you if
that is something you are worried about
the the choice is clear um and it is
important to elect those officials who
will preserve our health care
who will fight for the rights of lgbtq
persons who will continue
the march towards climate justice and
environmental rights
and will help us preserve what we have
left
and move us forward into the future uh
our next guest
is is the charlotte mayor i have the i
actually really enjoy listening to her
on
mpr when she's on the radio on on those
i think it's friday mornings maybe when
she's on
talking so i really enjoy hearing her
i've never met her but i know that she
is a wonderful woman
she is in her second term as mayor of
charlotte
she's led a real policy effort to
increase affordable housing
along with talking about transportation
and community safety
she's no stranger to charlotte politics
but we are grateful that she is here
tonight
to talk about the importance of voting
and all that is in store
for us this evening
thank you reverend lee i really
appreciate those kind words
i am so happy to be with you today
because we know that it's just 19 days
until we're going to elect a new
president and vice president of the
united states
i'm vi laos and i'm mayor of the 15th
largest city in this country
charlotte north carolina and i'm proud
to call it home
we're going to win in charlotte and
we're going to win
all across north carolina again because
we have taken
no votes for granted and we plan to
fight our way through
until november 30. i know we say this a
lot
but it bears repeating this is the most
important election of our lifetime
and the work we put in over the next
several weeks
is going to determine our country's
future for the next several decades
and everyone here needs to understand
that
now i've been fighting for justice and
equality and equity
for years in my city in my state
and i can tell you we have this moment
in time to make this difference
the people of north carolina are tired
of being lied to
they're tired of being disrespected
and they're looking for leadership
leadership that listens
understands and acts
i'm so proud to be a part of this effort
to restore the soul of our nation
and i can't imagine two people more
qualified
to lead this effort than joe biden and
kamala harris
joe and kamala understand that our
people need health care
a strong economy and we need some
leadership
to achieve racial justice in this
country
they know the struggles and the pathways
we have to take
but on the other hand they completely
understand our strength
and they know that we can take this on
we can experience this election that we
can win this
and we can make our country better
so what i would say to you early voting
started today in north carolina
so let's get out there let's start
taking advantage of this early voting as
the congresswoman my congresswoman said
there are 33
sites in charlotte right now open
still open for you to come out and vote
and let's continue not just the day you
know a lot of people like to come out on
just the first day
there's a second and a third all the way
until november the third
so let's make sure that we get out there
and you know if you have
any questions about this any doubt about
what you need to do to vote
visit iwillvote.com
backslash nc i will vote dot com
backslash nc
to get the information that you need to
get to the polls
and remember to take somebody with you a
neighbor
a cousin your mom just let's
do this let's make it work
so i know also that the president
the president that we need to defeat has
talked a lot about
poll watchers and things that are very
negative trying to
keep us away so if you need any
additional
assistance in voting just contact the
voter hotline
it's 1-833-868-3462-833-868-3462
you can get help in this in english and
spanish and many many
other languages if you have a question
or a concern
reach out because we're all in this
together
so let's get out there let's use our
power
and let's make sure our voices are heard
thank you reverend lee for the
opportunity
thank you kamala harris for visiting our
state
and we're going to make this happen for
the biden harris ticket
i hope you all can really sense the
excitement uh that is going on i think
that everybody here is very energized
for the opportunity not only to witness
history with the election of the joe
biden kamala harris ticket
but also to reclaim uh the soul of this
nation in the heart of this democracy
that we all wish to reclaim um
none of us have been uh unaffected by
the pandemic and the realities and
complexities
that it has presented that said it was
nice to be
at the early voting station today in my
county
and see old friends or people that i
hadn't seen at a distance of course
but being able to experience some
fellowship and some friendship
there in that place our next guest is
anthony hamilton
uh anthony is an american singer
songwriter and record producer
um he is a charlotte born son who is an
amazing amazing
uh recording artist he has been
nominated for 17
grammy awards uh and he has something
valuable to say to us today
so uh anthony hello everybody
um i'm excited to be here and excited to
represent north carolina one of the uh
the states that really really matter i
want to encourage people to get out and
vote
and vote with with all urgency
and to go out and vote for something
that matters uh vote for a team that has
integrity
um as class
has passion and someone who has
the you know the care of the people
concern for the people health care and
housing and things that that are that
are not there for people
underprivileged and underserved people
um
medical assistance and things that are
that are
not taken seriously um also
for the environment people who care
about the environment i think
clean air and clean water is so
important and uh
for people who who will make sure that
we get those things those essential
things that we need
as people um criminal justice
and and and and and you know a fight
against prejudice
and hate and and division amongst
people of color and people um and why in
the white community i think
as a family we should stand stand
together for things that matter
uh things that are humane and things
that are
that are just decent we need a house
that's decent
we need a white house that's set on
principle and we need a white house that
has love and passion
and and a white house that fears god
so that it can govern your decisions and
the things that
that make us better people so the biden
harris
ticket is definitely looking
more favorable for that i see a lot of
decency i see a lot of passion a lot of
love
and uh i'm so proud to be a part of it
and i will continue to represent and get
people to go out and vote
use my voice and my platform to
encourage those so north carolina that's
stand up show out and vote
big thank you so much for that anthony
and for uh your
remarks um some of you may be wondering
why the heck is a pastor uh
offering uh to emcee an event and uh
doing this and hosting and preparing
uh for our remarks from senator harris
um in 2017 my life was changed forever
i was reckoning with the realities
of charlottesville and as a descendant
of confederate general robert e lee
i was forced to choose do i side with
the
trump administration and the good people
on both sides mentality
or do i speak up and offer a word that
is different
and uh contrary to the administration's
uh
you know reality that they had presented
as that as that
played out i found myself on the stage
of the mtv video music awards
proclaiming that
black lives matter at a time when that
was not a phrase that needed to be
said by some in the trump administration
um
i found myself losing a job and finding
my soul again here in the heart of north
carolina
because i may have lost my job due to my
remarks about black lives matter
uh but i found a way to pave for justice
to work for justice in this community in
north carolina because we need it
uh we need leaders like roy cooper we
need hit leaders like senator harris
and vice president biden to take the
helm and remind
us of who we are and uh who we belong to
in the in a sense of each other we are
we are beholden to each other in this
moment
you know i think of uh my friend sloane
fleming she's 10 years old
she lives in california and she looks up
to senator harris
as a beacon of hope for all of children
across this country
who need to see a leader uh who can
offer us
dignity and decorum at a time when
that is absent in in the halls of power
i think of my parents
rusty and sherry lee who are about to
buy an rv and retire
they're hoping that their retirement uh
pays off after
years of hard work so my hope for them
is that through this election we will be
able to ensure that people like sloan
who are 10 years old
and my parents who are a little older
than that might be able to have a future
that is beautiful
and bright so as a descendant of robert
e lee the confederate general who led
to divide this country i'm proud to
introduce to you
uh someone who someone who i believe
will unite this country for a better
future
for a better tomorrow and for a brighter
uh joy that we have before us if we just
get out
and vote uh so friends uh let me
introduce to you
uh the vice presidential candidate for
the democratic party
uh the next vice president of the united
states of america
uh senator kamala harris
[Music]
thank you reverend lee and and for your
your leadership and your voice and your
courage
your commitment um for your love
of our country um it being rooted
in in a faith that that teaches us
so well um that we must always fight for
justice
if we are to to live god's plan for all
of us
um and i just want to thank you you've
been
um a real inspiration to so many people
and
i think that your story and the way you
live your life
and um and and use your word
is is about who we really are which is a
country
that is born out of many things but but
can
always fight um for unity and
um and togetherness and kindness so
thank you for that
and um to everyone greetings all my
friends you know i was supposed to be
with you in person today
and other things happen but i love i
love
i love north carolina um and
i was there just i think it was last
week we lose track of time these days
and i will certainly be back but it is
so great to be with everyone i want to
thank
all of the leaders um sarah gerbach
mayor mannheimer um thank you i know i
was supposed to be in nashville with you
um my dear dear dear sister and friend
alma adams for all that you do and thank
you for always sending me such a kind
and inspiring note
um mayor lyles thank you always
um and of course anthony hamilton i'm
such a huge fan i said anthony hamilton
the singer
i was so excited um to be with you and
thank you for your
talent and your skill and your gift that
you just share with so many of us
and um mbb same thing
bibi wrote this most beautiful song
about this moment
and um thank you for the gift of your
voice
um and and again thank you to everyone
so
as you all know i was supposed to be
there and
late last night um we got word
that that two of the folks involved with
our campaign
one who is a um who is a a
flight crew staff not he doesn't work on
our staff but works
on on the flights um and and and my
communications director liz that they
contracted coveted 19. i've talked to
both of them they are well
um they're doing well the last time i
saw them was
seven days ago i had many tests now and
they are all negative
um and i am fine i'm good but um we want
to just be
cautious because that's where we've been
as a campaign to take this seriously and
to
hopefully model the kind of behaviors we
should all be engaged in to
to be safe but i i will i'm on the road
virtually as you can see
um i just left wisconsin to join you in
north carolina
and i'll be back physically on the road
on monday but i want to just thank you
all for accommodating the change in
schedule
and um and for all that you do and i'd
remind everybody let's
let's adhere to the cdc guidelines and
be safe
and as an extension of loving
thy neighbor so here we are
we are 19 days away from this election
which is going to decide so much
about not only the future of our country
but really
who we are who we are presently and
what we what we want for ourselves and
what we believe in
um like joe says all the time this this
campaign in this election is really
about a full a fight for the soul of our
nation
and and i really do believe that and the
stakes of course could not be higher
we're facing at least four crises
all happening at once um of course
quoted and what that has meant in terms
of a public health crisis
and i don't need to tell north carolina
what that has meant in terms of
you know nationally over 215 000
people have died in just the last
several months so many without
because of the nature of the virus
without family to be there with them for
their last
hours on earth um you know seven and a
half million
or more people who've contracted this
virus with
unknown long-term impact um and but
which also by the way
it's gonna mean that there are now seven
and a half million people who will now
have this new
um pre-existing condition which which
should require protection so that
insurance companies can't deny them care
we're looking at an economic crisis over
30 million people
in just the last several months file for
unemployment
we're in the midst of a hunger crisis
we're not talking enough about people
are in food lines
you know hoping and praying that by the
time they get to the end of the food
line there'll be food left
mothers i saw a number of mothers one in
five mothers is describing her children
under the age of 12 as being hungry
uh we're in the midst of a a crisis that
is about a generational
crisis and a reckoning on the issue of
racial
justice and injustice in our country and
then we're
also facing a climate crisis um where
you know
i my home state of california so many
western states
oregon was washington are looking at
wildfires that are raging
families are becoming displaced
firefighters have died fighting those
fires
i'm on the gulf coast how those storms
have been ravaging communities
um in in places like iowa the the
flooding
that has caused farmers to lose a whole
season of crops
so all this is happening and
i believe that at this moment with these
crises converging
it is requiring all of us to really
ask this question which is a question
about
you know who are we who are we as a
country and i think we all know we are
better than this
and we have to fight and we have to
fight in particular for the ideals of
our country
and and fight for what's right and fight
for each other's
um for a recognition of each other's
dignity
that is as much as anything what is at
play and i'm so honored to be on this
ticket with joe biden
um you know the contrast between he and
donald trump could not be more stark
in every way and on every subject
that i just hit upon you know on the one
hand you have joe
biden who together with barack obama
created the affordable care act which
brought health care to millions of
people
joe biden and i want to come in and
expand the affordable care act
um but what it did we have to remember
is it said
and as part of its its spirit and joe
feels very strongly about this
health care and access to health care
should be a right
not just a privilege of those who can
afford it and so
the affordable care act expanded
healthcare so over 20 million people who
didn't have coverage gut coverage
it it said people with pre-existing
conditions like
you know you may know somebody or you
yourself may have diabetes
that was considered a pre-existing
condition high blood pressure
breast cancer and and this
this affordable care act also known as
obamacare said
no you cannot be discriminated against
and be denied or charged more for health
coverage because you have a pre-existing
condition
and again now we're looking at over
seven and a half million people who have
this new pre-existing condition of copen
19.
and joe biden is saying let's keep that
intact and expand the affordable
care act so on the one hand you have joe
biden on the other hand you have donald
trump who is in court right now
in the united states supreme court
trying to get rid of
the affordable care act and you know
i've said it i said
i think on the debate stage he's got
some weird obsession
with trying to get rid of anything that
barack obama and joe biden created
but when you look at the issue of
the affordable care act and its
protections and you couple that with the
fact that we are in a public health
crisis
it is absolutely outrageous and that's
one of the biggest
areas that is impacting north carolinian
voters
and people across our country which is
the thing that keeps people up at night
the thing which is that they don't want
to go bankrupt families should never go
bankrupt because they need to pay for
health care
and they can't afford it so these are
some of the issues
that are at play our economy joe's plan
our plan is about saying we're going to
invest in our economy and in working
people we will invest in
infrastructure and create millions of
jobs we will invest in our small
businesses
i have met small business leaders in
north carolina incredible
innovators who deserve to have the
support not only to stay
open or open back up after the pandemic
but access to low interest loans so that
they can continue
to thrive and grow these are kind of
things that joe and i
are committed to we're committed to
saying that we need to invest in public
schools
and triple title one funding that
impacts a lot of schools in north
carolina schools title one finance
a fancy way basically saying schools
that are in
low tax based communities and so
they are schools that have great need
and that needs to be met we're saying
we're going to triple that funding which
includes then
supporting the teachers who teach in
those schools
these are some of the issues that are at
play in this election
and speaking specifically about the
impact of north carolina
um look kovic there have been over 236
000 cases and over
3 800 deaths in north carolina because
of this virus um in terms of the
the the economy which in many ways is
being compared to the great depression
um in north carolina august unemployment
was six and a half percent which is
almost
twice what it was in february
and don't forget donald trump knew about
this on january 28th and didn't tell you
didn't tell the people
when we could have planned when folks
could have planned and and could have
figured out
maybe how they could save up a little
extra if it was likely that they would
be
out of work for a while but since
in north carolina since february when it
was 3.6 it is now
in august six and a half percent
unemployment in north carolina one
in 10 adults did not have enough to eat
in the month of september that's what we
have in terms of the reporting
and when you look at the the number of
unemployment
claims almost 40 percent of black
americans
um were filed for unemployment um in the
month of august despite being 22 percent
of the population
so these are some of the realities these
are the facts of what is going on
and and then you look at what joe is
talking about and again it's about
investing in american workers and in
american families investing in
infrastructure investing in our schools
investing in our future
and doing it in a way that we retain and
return
dignity to the white house in a way that
we have a president
who has in his deepest heart
a desire a strong desire based on a
history of doing this
to stand up for working families to
stand up for the dignity of work and to
stand up
for the dignity of all people and
recognizing that we are
a strong nation when we are unified
so my last point is this
this election ends in 19
days yes i that's what i said calmly did
you say it ends in 19 days yes i did i
said it ends in 19 days
because you see north carolina early
voting
begins today on october 15th
i can't believe i actually did it and so
we want you to start voting october 15th
we want you to start voting and vote
early
and here's the other thing we want to
make sure that we vote
up and down the ticket because you've
got an important senate race in north
carolina
you got to re-elect my friend we worked
together when we were ages roy cooper
and reelect him as governor and and and
and you got to make sure that we do
everything we can to deal with this up
and down the ticket in north carolina
you're one of the few states that has
you're voting for president senator and
governor all at the same time
so um let's make sure everybody votes
and votes early and then
the last one i'll make is please go to
iwillvote.com
and sign up to make sure that you know
where you can vote to make sure you're
registered
but more than anything else please vote
early
make a plan to vote early encourage your
friends and your families to make a plan
to vote early
figure out where you're going to vote
when you're going to um and and
and get out there because the most
important thing that we can do at this
moment in time
is make sure our voices are heard and
the best way to do that is through our
vote
so thank you all very very much and on
behalf of joe and myself
we cannot cannot tell you how grateful
we are
for all that you do every day and all
that we will together do
for these next 19 days thank you
[Music]
doesn't
[Music]
[Music]
you